[Applaudissements]
comme un symbole les gros castillo a
prêté serment le jour du bicentenaire de
l'indépendance du pérou un pays marqué
par la corruption et la pauvreté et qui
fait désormais confiance
un homme du peuple c'est la première
fois que notre pays sera gouverné par un
paysan une personne qui appartient quand
beaucoup de paix revient aux classes
sociales qui ont été opprimés pendant
tant de siècles
c'est aussi la première fois comme parti
politique formé à l'intérieur du pays
remporte ces élections de manière
démocratique
c'est l'une de ses promesses et pedro
castillo veut mettre fin à la corruption
dans un pays marqué par de nombreux
scandales politiques nous devons
éradiquer la corruption
mais pour ce faire nous devons punir
sévèrement et fermement tous ceux qui
s'y livrent les chantiers sont de taille
pour le nouveau président à commencer
par la gestion de la crise sanitaire au
pérou 195 milles personnes sont mortes
ducobu soit le taux de mortalité le plus
élevé au monde par rapport à la
population une crise sanitaire qui a
entraîné une crise économique le pays
déjà pauvres avant la pandémie s'est
effondrée ces derniers mois avec une
perte de deux millions d'emplois et une
chute de 11% de son pib en 2020 et pour
le relancer et pedro castillo veut
réformer la constitution de 1993 qui
l'accusent de favoriser l'économie de
marché je vous annonce que nous
soumettrons congrès de la république
dans le strict respect de la procédure
de réforme constitutionnelle prévu à
l'article 206 de la constitution
actuelle un projet de loi de réforme de
la constitution
pedro castillo devra également
gouverner pour un peuple en attente de
réponse et qui veut désormais avoir son
mot à dire dans la reconstruction du
pont
c'est le début le début d'une histoire
démocratique où pour la première fois le
peuple va contribuer à façonner ce
gouvernement bagdad harper c'est un
paysan originaire du fin fond du pérou
et nous en sommes heureux toute la
population de san juan de lurigancho et
du pérou le soutiendra maintenant qu'il
a fait une déclaration allant dans le
sens d'un changement de la constitution
pour pedro castilloux reste désormais à
convaincre un parlement où il ne dispose
pas de la majorité est habitué à une
politique ultra libérale depuis 25 ans
le chef de l'état devra aussi rassurer
le peuple méfiants envers la gauche
depuis le sentier lumineux
le parti communiste et radicale péruvien
auquel on impute la mort de soixante dix
mille personnes dans les années 1980 et